hey 42 here for most of us when were
people watching the normal thoughts that
come into our heads are I wonder where
they're going is that a couple are they
wearing those clothes for it well there
are a select few of us whose first
thoughts when they spot a face in the
crowd is mustard or gravy human meat the
great Forbidden delicacy has been eaten
throughout history because of rituals
desperate bent for survival curiosity
and when Tesco ran out of horse meat
cannibalism or anthropology as it's
officially known is still practiced
today in places like Indonesia New
Guinea but has generally been the last
resort of those with no other choice
like when you're stuck up a mountain or
adrift on the ocean so where does the
law stand on this and how about your
doctor how would he feel about literally
taking your pound of flesh today we find
out can you eat in most part of the
world there has been an extreme disdain
for cannibalism which you can see
reflected in the myths and folklore
that's used as an example of truly
depraved behavior such as in Hansel and
Gretel and stories of the witch Baba
Yaga in Greek mythology Tantalus was
punished for boiling up his son Pelops
and serving him to the gods he was sent
to the deepest corner of the underworld
and his fitting castigation was that
when he was hungry and grasped for a
grape it was always just too high and
the water below him always shrunk away
whenever he tried to quench his first
this is where we get the word
tantalizing something that is just out
of reach for those tribes that did
indulge in the practice of cannibalism
it was either to absorb the power of
those that they had killed such as the
strength of rival warriors or it was a
process of breathing and will be done to
the bodies of friends and family members
I am assuming the flowers were used as
some sort of side salad many seeds is
for our history such as Jerusalem in 70
AD and the first Crusades have reports
of soldiers and civilians have
to cannibalize to fallen when all
supplies have been exhausted in World
War two during the 872 day assault on
Leningrad now st. Petersburg the police
had to form an anti cannibalism division
which was only slightly more popular
than traffic duty well what do you want
to give a ticket to a tank of course
human beings are not alone in this merry
sport there are plenty of animal species
who will happily chew their way through
their odd cousin such as the usually
vegetarian hippos who were found
chomping on a decaying hippo carcass
during a very difficult year but for
some species especially at the early
stages of development
cannibalism is programmed to kick in
depending on the environment as a form
of species preservation when tiger
salamanders are born if there's not too
many larvae then they all develop nice
and friendly and remember to buy each
other socks for Christmas but at some
point when it all gets a bit overcrowded
then a random selection start growing
with a broader head and triple length
teeth and rather than chasing the normal
dinner of aquatic invertebrate they
devour the smaller salamanders who are
the most nutritious available meal
around they have cannibalism coded into
their DNA to make sure that at least
some of the offspring survive when
there's not enough food to go around
it's a bit like a mother of five
throwing two cheeseburgers into a
kitchen and then locking all the doors
ignore the screaming it's for their own
good and if you think that's mean of mum
well nature has its own revenge plans
there if you didn't think spiders were
already awful enough the crab spider
mother lays extra unfertilized eggs for
her young to eat but greedy sideways
walking sticky strings
viewing agents of Satan that they are
it's not enough and they also eat their
own mother over a few weeks
honestly this generation no respect this
is called Matra Fergie which means
mother eating and well I'll just let you
go ahead and make your own joke there so
back to humans or like these salamanders
spiders or humans are clearly not
genetically designed to eat our own
flesh so is it safe
in the 1930s Australian gold prospectors
discovered that there was a huge
population of Native people living in
the Highlands of Papua New Guinea an
area where we have fought to be
relatively empty before them over the
next few decades as researchers began to
spend time with these people they found
there was a very mysterious disease that
was killing around 200 of them a year in
the 11,000 strong for tribe it was known
as kuru meaning trembling since
sufferers will quickly lose control over
their limbs as well as their emotions
once it took hold it took about a year
before they were completely
incapacitated the obvious suspicion was
that it was some rare genetic condition
that had been passed down within the
small DNA pool of the tribe but as they
tracked the victims they realized that
there was a correlation with social
groups but not with genetic groups so
there must be an environmental reason
for the disease and of course you have
already guessed what it was before
believe that it was better to eat their
dead than to leave it as food for the
world
so they whipped up a cranial stew of
brain fern and bamboo whilst the rest of
the body was roasted over the fire it's
thought that at some point one of the
four must have developed CJD the human
form of mad cow disease and then that
was spread through the tribe not as a
virus or bacteria but by eating the
brain prions of ottoman tribe members
which is a messed up kind of protein
this method of transmission could take
decades to take hold and begin the
mysterious kuru so from a doctors point
of view eating humans is probably right
up there with smoking drinking
super-sized sodas and that thing you do
when the doors closed it makes you go
blind apparently doctors is one thing
but what about lawyers do they enjoy the
taste of human I mean is it from a legal
perspective okay to consume another
person obviously killing people is off
the tape that's not
okay but can you take a nibble on a
corpse if you come across one in the
forest as a and what about in the case
of desperation much of the ruling that
exists is built around a Law School
classic called Regina versus Dudley and
Stevenson's from 1884 with Regina being
Queen Victoria at that point a ship
called the Mineola was sailing from
Southampton to Sydney when it hits a
gale knee in the Cape of Good Hope and
they had to abandon ship ending up in a
lifeboat with just some navigation
equipment and two tins of turnips
there were four people in total the
captain Tom Dudley two sailors Edwin
Stevenson's and Edwin Brooks and a 17
year old cabin boy named Richard Parker
after two days they ate the first tin of
turnips I'm sure it was very delicious a
couple of days later they managed to
kill a turtle and this along with the
other tourniquet in let them survive to
almost two weeks at sea Richard Parker
fell very ill and slipped into a
probable coma after much discussion and
almost twenty days in the lifeboat
Dudley pushed his penknife into the boys
neck while Stevens held his legs both
claims that Brooks had agreed to this
but he denied it they all ate the dead
boy and four or five days later they
were rescued they told the truth when
they came back to England and a major
case ensued with Brooks turning against
to two other men as state's witness both
Dudley and Stevens were found guilty of
murder and sentenced to death although
they were eventually released after six
months in prison back to the Home
Secretary William Harcourt so killing
for food in case of emergency is not
okay apparently but what about
cannibalism without the killing part
Canadian artist Rick Gibson obviously
having run out of painting canvasses
decided to eat the flesh of another
person in public in 1988 he ate a canapé
made out of donated tonsils in London
and the UK has no specific law against
this the next year though he set the bar
even lower when he ate a human testicle
when he tried the
same thing in Vancouver but they
confiscated his snack and charged him
with publicly exhibiting a disgusting
object but the case was dropped and
having waited almost two months he
hungrily finished his lunch on the
courthouse steps after the verdict the
media went nuts I mean they had a ball
Oh
all in all it's a good thing that the
social taboo and the medical dangers
have kept us from stacking on our
friends and family but to keep
temptation at a minimum make sure you
never sit too near the fire and maybe we
think that bacon and maple syrup do dirt
you're just asking for trouble thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 you may be either grossed out
when I tell you this or totally amazed
but inside the chrysalis the caterpillar
completely liquid Isis these are some of
the most at it and most dangerous
recreational drugs in the world but
there's an even more dangerous drug